il y a urgence
urgence face à la crise climatique qui
provoque les dérèglements que nous
constatons tous mégafeux inondations
sécheresse plus que plus que jamais
personne ne peut regarder ailleurs
urgence également face à la crise
énergétique la plus grave depuis les
années 70 vous le savez devoir apporter
des énergies sans en maîtriser le coup
c'est affaiblir le pouvoir d'achat des
Français c'est peser sur la
compétitivité de nos entreprises
c'est réduire les capacités
d'investissement des collectivités
locales face à ces enjeux nous ne sommes
pas en solution
bonjour et bienvenue dans les grands
débats aujourd'hui on s'intéresse dans
ce nouveau numéro un projet de loi celui
sur l'accélération de la production des
énergies renouvelables double objectif
favoriser la souveraineté énergétique de
la France et répondre à la crise
climatique le texte arrive dans
l'hémicycle le 5 décembre dernier et
c'est Agnès panhir une hachée la
ministre de la transition énergétique
qui le défend un texte voté un mois
auparavant par les sénateurs avec cette
loi la France entend bien rattraper son
retard dans le déploiement des énergies
renouvelables
deux tiers
c'est la part d'énergie fossile dans
notre consommation finale d'énergie deux
tiers de gaz de fioul de carburant dont
nous ne pouvons aujourd'hui pas nous
passer pour nous déplacer pour nous
chauffer ou pour notre industrie deux
tiers d'énergie fossile importée au
détriment de notre balance commerciale
comme de notre souveraineté
2035 c'est la date à laquelle 26 de nos
56 réacteurs nucléaires arriveront au
terme de 50 années d'exploitation tous
devront alors passer le cap d'un
contrôle de sûreté approfondi pour être
prolongé 10 années de plus en matière
énergétique 2035 c'est demain
60% c'est selon RTE la proportion
d'électricité que nous devons produire
en plus à l'horizon 2050 pour répondre à
nos besoins croissants d'électrification
pour l'industrie pour les transports et
les bâtiments si nous venons devenir le
premier grand pays industriel au monde à
sortir des énergies fossiles et à
atteindre la neutralité carbone
mesdames et messieurs les députés ces
trois chiffres montrent bien que nous
sommes à un tournant historique et si
nous voulons devenir enfin maître de
notre destin énergétique nous ne
pourrons nous passer d'aucune énergie
décarbonée nucléaire comme renouvelable
tant la marche à franchir et haute
lorsque je dis renouvelable je parle
bien sûr de toutes les énergies
renouvelables celles qui produisent de
l'électricité comme celle qui produisent
de la chaleur grâce au travail des
experts du GIEC du Haut Conseil pour le
climat ou de RTE nous savons qu'elles
doivent être les votre piliers
intangibles de notre action la sobriété
et l'efficacité énergétique tout d'abord
le 6 octobre dernier avec la première
ministre j'ai présenté un plan de
sobriété qui vise à réduire de 10% notre
consommation d'énergie d'ici 2024 l'État
comme des centaines d'entreprises et de
collectivités locales sont déjà
mobilisés pour y parvenir nous menons
également des actions ambitieuses en
matière d'efficacité énergétique sur la
rénovation thermique des bâtiments le
verdissement des transports ou encore
sur la décarbonation profonde de notre
industrie le rapport de RTE nous le
démontre d'ici 2050 si nous voulons
atteindre la neutralité carbone il nous
faudra réduire de 40%, notre
consommation d'énergie finale
le déploiement massif des énergies
renouvelables en suite c'est tout le
sens du grand plan énergie renouvelable
que j'ai lancé en juin dernier grâce à
ce plan nous avons débloqué 10 gigawatts
de production électrique et 1 terawater
de biométhane pour accompagner assurer
la réussite de ce plan nous avons
renforcé les effectifs des équipes
d'instruction sur le terrain et nous
avons adressé une circulaire au préfet
et service des concentrés de l'État pour
s'assurer de leur implication et leur
engagement sur les énergies
renouvelables c'est en tout près de 30
textes réglementaires qui ont été
présentés depuis mai devant le Conseil
supérieur de l'énergie le texte que j'ai
l'honneur de vous présenter aujourd'hui
constitue le volet législatif de ce plan
global
la relance d'un programme nucléaire
ambitieux comme la proposer le président
de la République cela fait l'objet d'un
débat public qui a été engagé en octobre
et qui est menée par la Commission
nationale du débat public jusqu'à fin
février 2023 afin d'anticiper car nous
n'avons pas de temps à perdre nous
travaillons à simplifier les procédures
administratives de construction de
nouveaux réacteurs à proximité des sites
qui en accueillent déjà c'est tout
l'objet du projet de loi qui vous sera
présenté début 2023
quels sont les grands chapitres de notre
stratégie énergétique personne ne peut
donc douter de la détermination du
président de la République mesdames et
messieurs les députés je sais
qu'ensemble durant les heures qui sont
devant nous nous saurons encore
améliorer le texte et je suis confiante
sur le fait que de gauche à droite dans
cette hémicycle parmi les nombreuses
bonnes volontés qui siègent nous serons
aussi nous accorder sur l'essentiel
l'essentiel c'est faire face à la crise
énergétique pour le pouvoir d'achat des
Français et la compétitivité des
entreprises c'est défendre
l'indépendance industrielle énergétique
et politique de notre pays
c'est lutter contre le dérèglement
climatique pour l'avenir de nos enfants
car c'est bien tout l'enjeu de ce texte
je vous remercie
merci madame la ministre
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à Monsieur henrial Fondary
rapporteur de la commission des affaires
économiques madame la présidente madame
la ministre Messieurs les Présidents
Mesdames et Messieurs les rapporteurs
chers collègues l'heure est venue pour
notre assemblée de commencer l'examen du
projet de loi relatif à l'accélération
de la production d'énergie renouvelables
qui a suscité de longs débats au Sénat
les sénateurs nous ont apporté une
excellente base de travail sur laquelle
nous avons pu nous appuyer en commission
et nous les remercions pour ce travail
la guerre en Ukraine nous le rappelle
l'enjeu primordial est de retrouver
notre souveraineté énergétique et de
moins dépendre des autres pays
nul besoin d'étendre nos discussions sur
la relance de la production nucléaire
nous aurons l'occasion d'échanger
longuement sur ce sujet au début de
l'année prochaine cependant il est
évident que construire de nouveaux
réacteurs prendra de nombreuses années
nous ne pouvons attendre de tels
échéances pour entreprendre la
décarbonation de notre société
neutralité carbone en 2050 c'est dès
maintenant qu'il faut réussir un profond
revirement de nos productions et de nos
usages notre retard actuel dans
l'atteinte des objectifs de notre
politique énergétique exige
détermination et ambitions pour nous
permettre de dépasser les résultats déjà
accomplis
les cinq prochaines années seront
décisives pour réussir le tournant du
renouvelable nous pouvons nous réjouir
d'avoir établi une planification qui
consacre les habitants et leurs élus
soient les territoires comme Pierre
d'édifice de notre action
le retour d'un état facilitateur et
accompagnateur pour que les choix issus
de la concertation soit infinés les
réalisations concrètes issues de leur
volonté je vous remercie
merci Monsieur
Pierre Cazeneuve rapporteur pour avis de
la commission du développement durable
et de l'aménagement du territoire
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui
65% de notre consommation énergétique et
de l'énergie fossile importée
cela constitue à la fois une
extraordinaire
dépendante vis-à-vis de certains pays
mais aussi un impact particulièrement
conséquent sur nos émissions de gaz à
effet de serre
ce projet de loi il répond donc à un
double objectif le premier c'est
renforcer notre souveraineté énergétique
le second c'est lutter contre le
dérèglement climatique pour se faire
nous devons actionner deux leviers le
premier c'est la sobriété et
l'efficience
en réduisant de 40% notre consommation
énergétique d'ici 2050 le second
c'est la production massive d'énergie
décarbonée à savoir le nucléaire et les
énergies renouvelables
actuellement pour accorder un projet
d'énergie renouvelable nous mettons deux
fois plus de temps que nous voisins
européens pour ne prendre
qu'un exemple
le parc d'éolienne en mer de
Saint-Nazaire quand il a débuté je
passais mon brevet des collèges il a été
inauguré seulement cette année par le
Président de la République
le projet de loi doit nous permettre de
rattraper notre retard grâce à quatre
grands axes
planifiez le déploiement des énergies
renouvelables dans nos territoires en
partant des communes rationaliser et
accélérer les procédures administratives
faciliter l'implantation sur des
terrains déjà artificialisés et enfin
développer le partage territorial de la
valeur le tout en préservant notre
biodiversité et la nécessaire
participation du public les débats en
commission étaient passionnants
particulièrement riches et je ne doute
pas que nous poursuivrons dans cette
même dynamique l'examen en hémicycle et
dans ce même esprit pour voter là encore
ensemble ce texte et ne plus jamais
à devoir à ouvrir de centrales à charbon
je terminerai en remerciant mes
collègues co-rapporteurs madame Aude
Luquet Monsieur Henri al-fandari
monsieur Éric Bothorel madame la
ministre bien entendu ainsi que
l'ensemble de son cabinet l'ensemble des
chefs de fil qui ont contribué à ces
débats en commission et bien évidemment
les administratrices qui nous ont
accompagnés tout au long de ce texte je
vous remercie
la parole est à monsieur Éric bottorel
rapporteur de la commission des affaires
économiques
les Français reconnaissent aujourd'hui
que pour faire face aux enjeux du climat
et à la décarbonation des activités la
rapide mobilisation et le déploiement
des énergies renouvelables est
nécessaire aux côtés du renforcement de
nos capacités en énergie nucléaire
ils sont récemment 81% à considérer que
l'installation de nouvelles fermes de
panneaux solaires est importante et 40%
estiment qu'il s'agit d'une priorité un
sondage récent paru une façon dans Les
Echos ce texte traduit cette attente
légitime et nous ne pouvons pas les
décevoir afin d'accroître notre
stratégique de lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique de sortir de
notre dépendance aux énergies fossiles
et d'atteindre la neutralité carbone en
2050 notre stratégie énergétique doit
être ambitieuse elle tient en trois mots
sobriété nucléaire renouvelables ce
triptyque fixe un cap et permettra à la
France de devenir une véritable
puissance écologique et souveraine en
matière d'énergie renouvelable la France
est en retard sur ses objectifs il nous
faut donc accélérer radicalement en
divisant par deux les délais entre la
décision et la mise en service des
installations c'est l'ambition du texte
que nous examinons aujourd'hui
ce projet de loi mobilise tous les
leviers d'accélération disponibles
procédure simplifiée nouveau site
d'implantation et nouveau leviers
financier le tout avec l'implication
étroite des acteurs locaux dans le
déploiement des projets le travail
collectif en commission du développement
durable et en commission des affaires
économiques et je salue à ce stade mes
collègues rapporteurs d'édits
commissions a permis d'acter de
nombreuses avancées et je salue l'esprit
de compromis de mes collègues députés et
du gouvernement
sur la question de la révoltaïsme le
Sénat a posé une première pierre en
proposant une définition perfectible les
nombreux entretiens menés en commission
avec les acteurs de la filière ont
permis de nous forger une conviction les
agriculteurs doivent avoir l'opportunité
de se saisir de ce nouvel outil au
service de l'agriculture sans que les
panneaux ne remplacent les troupeaux et
sans que la production d'électricité ne
vienne concurrencer la production et
l'emploi agricole nous avons donc
proposé et voter les améliorations de la
définition initiale en préservant les
fonctions écologiques des sols et en
interdisant le défrichement en zone
forestière pour l'implantation de
panneaux photovoltaïques j'espère que le
travail en séance nous permettra de
parachever cet encadrement concernant le
foncier davantage de terrain sont
libérés pour nos énergies renouvelables
le Conservatoire de l'espace littoral et
les rivages lacustres et désormais
consulté pour l'élaboration de la liste
des friches pouvant faire l'objet d'un
aménagement photovoltaïque dérogations
aux principes d'implantation en
continuité urbaine dans les zones et de
montagne sont ouvertes avec un
encadrement pour protéger ses
territoires fragiles plusieurs articles
viennent ensuite valoriser le potentiel
de l'hydroélectricité qui a l'avantage
d'être la plus pilotable des
renouvelables et les débits minimaux des
cours d'eau peuvent dorénavant être
relevés en cas de menace sur la sécurité
la provisionnement en électricité le
salut sur ce point le travail de ma
collègue marine Noël Battistel dont on
ne peut m'y connaître son investissement
sur le sujet hydro sur ce point la
rédaction issue de la commission
garantie un suivi des impacts sur les
biodiversités résultant d'une telle
mesure ainsi que la mise en place d'une
affectation des recettes supplémentaires
ainsi générer à des actions en faveur de
la biodiversité le six équipement des
concessions hydroélectriques est
également simplifiée concernant la
méthanisation et le vecteur d'hydrogène
nous soutenons résolument leur essor le
travail en commission a permis de
sécuriser juridiquement le développement
de la méthanisation en zone agricole
tout en conservant l'ambition d'une
extension rationnelle et maîtrisée de
ces unités le cadre juridique pour le
déploiement du gaz bas carbone et lui
aussi précisé
nous facilitons ensuite la Constitution
d'opérations d'autoconsommation
collective ainsi que la conclusion de
Power patcher Grimentz c'est-à-dire de
contrats directs entre un producteur
d'énergie renouvelable et un
consommateur le Sénat a ouvert aux
collectivités la possibilité de
souscrire des pipiers ce qui est un
ajout bienvenu sur le partage de la
valeur produite par les énergies
renouvelables qui concourent à
l'acceptabilité des installations la
Commission à réintroduit le principe
d'un partage avec les riverains et à
maintenir le dispositif à destination
des collectivités territoriales souhaité
par le Sénat les producteurs d'énergie
renouvelables lauréats des mises à
concurrence ont désormais l'obligation
de financer des projets de protection de
la biodiversité la séance publique
devrait permettre d'améliorer et
d'affiner davantage le partage de la
valeur entre les producteurs d'énergie
renouvelables et les collectivités le
texte conforte par ailleurs la
possibilité pour les riverains du lieu
de production et pour les communes et
leurs groupements concernées de
participer au capital social d'une
entreprise porteuse d'un projet de
production d'énergie renouvelable
j'aurais à cœur de m'assurer que ces
mécanismes de partage de la valeur soit
opérationnelle et qu'il ne crée pas
d'effet de seuil ou de rupture d'égalité
entre les citoyens en définitive le
présent projet de loi tel qui suit les
travaux de la commission des affaires
économiques s'inscrit résolument dans
une volonté d'équilibre entre
accélération de la production d'énergie
renouvelable et préservation des autres
enjeux liés à l'occupation des nouvelles
surfaces
je vous remercie
merci monsieur beaucourrel
les objectifs du texte apparaissent
consensuels et le gouvernement compte
bien faire des compromis mais des
positions irréponseillables s'affrontent
dans l'hémicycle autour des éoliennes
elle reste très controversée certains
défendent la nécessaire accélération des
énergies des carbonées quand d'autres
dénoncent des nuisances dans les
paysages mais en ce début d'hiver 2022
c'est surtout le déficit de production
nucléaire qui est pointée du doigt par
de nombreux députés à l'époque 30
réacteurs sur 56 sont à l'arrêt de quoi
mettre à mal l'approvisionnement
énergétique du pays
nous passons à la discussion générale la
parole est à Monsieur jumelles du groupe
Gauche démocrate et républicaine
[Applaudissements]
allons-nous passer l'hiver
pas de panique nous rassure-t-on au
Palais de l'Élysée il y aura pas de
coupure si le temps est bon s'il n'y a
pas trop de vent s'il ne pleut pas s'il
fait beau peut-être bref si nous avons
de la chance
tous responsables et pas de panique
voilà un slogan qui aurait pu lancer le
capitaine du Titanic
en plein milieu du naufrage
scar l'iceberg est devant nous la coque
du navire son approche à pleine vitesse
et à défaut d'une véritable stratégie
pour son détourner évitez ainsi des
mesures de détestage humiliantes et aux
conséquences difficiles pour les ménages
pour les entreprises le gouvernement
nous a dégoté un nouvel outil aussi
gadget que dérisoire et coat
le nouveau Bison Futé des délaissage qui
nous permet de savoir dans quel état se
trouve le réseau électrique comment ils
risquent d'être coupé surtout à quelle
heure un outil pour gérer la peur et la
panique plutôt que pour gérer la crise
puisque nous ne savons pas quels sont
les mesures concrètes qui vont nous
permettre de passer l'hiver le déficit
de production d'électricité d'origine
nucléaire que nous connaissons
actuellement avec l'arrêt à cette heure
encore de 23 réacteurs sur 56 s'il le
fait de carénage et le fruit de de
sous-investissement chronique est aussi
le fruit de renoncement alors que faire
dans ce contexte le gouvernement nous
propose d'inverser des sujets et des
débats au lieu de discuter du plan nous
travaillons d'abord à ces détails avec
le projet de loi visant à accélérer les
EnR autrement dit alors que nous
manquons de sécurité sur
l'approvisionnement pour équilibrer
l'équilibre offre demande nous cherchons
à développer des moyens non pilotables
en urgence sans plan sans stratégie et
surtout sans maîtrise publique
car si nous savons qu'il est essentiel
de développer un mix énergétique
équilibré diversifié qui rattrape le
retard pris par le pays sur ce point
nous avons besoin d'un développement
public planifié exemplaire concerté
intégrant les conflits d'usage à terre
comme en mer c'est évidemment une
préoccupation majeure que nous formulons
hors depuis de nombreuses années la
montée en puissance des ENR s'est faite
au détriment de l'emploi local de
l'industrie made in France et de cette
maîtrise publique que nous attendons
nourri appuyé par l'obligation d'achat
le complément de rémunération les EnR
ont ainsi pu largement bénéficié d'un
soutien public sans jamais que la
Commission européenne d'ailleurs n'y
trouve rien n'a redire des dizaines de
milliards d'euros ont ainsi permis à
tous les porteurs projets privés
d'investir nos paysages la montée en
puissance des ENR s'est faite sans
planification un développement
anarchique qui a répondu à une seule
logique celle du marché les porteurs de
projets ont développé ainsi la plus
rentable et la plus facile exemple
l'éolien plutôt que la géothermie les
porteurs de projets ont également fait
le choix de concentrer les installations
là où la rentabilité et la plus évidente
la plus immédiate chez les pauvres
Hauts-de-France Grand Est ou nord de la
Seine-Maritime ou la saturation commence
à se faire jour une logique qui a suivi
également l'éolien en mer l'exemple
parfait de ce que le marché peut faire à
nos écosystèmes marins en mépris total à
la volonté des élus des pêcheurs et
celui du projet au large du Tréport ce
projet de loi est un signal au marché en
France ces deux armées open bar au
développement son contrainte des ENR
rien ne sera entravé les VRP des
éoliennes des panneaux solaires car rien
n'existe dans ce projet ou pas grand
chose devrais-je dire pour empêcher le
développement hors des zones telles
qu'elles sont définies prioritairement
par les mères ce projet de loi ne
revient sur rien et proposons contraire
d'accélérer la mise en miette de la
péréquation tarifaire même si j'ai cru
comprendre qu'un amendement visait à
corriger cela on l'examinera évidemment
avec attention nous alertons je termine
par là nos collègues y compris
l'ensemble des collègues de gauche qui
sont attachés et de droite qui sont
attachées à l'unicité d'EDF car ce
projet peut constituer le premier levier
la première marche le premier cheval de
Troie qui dessine le retour déguisé
d'Hercule de points 0 ce projet que vous
attendez tant pour démanteler une fois
pour toute EDF après avoir livré les EnR
au marché et à la rentabilité vous allez
investir dans les EPR préparer à la
découpe notre fleuron et si nous passons
l'hiver nous
au travers de votre préparation vous
concoctez un plan qui nous permet de
douter sur le fait que EDF ne peut pas
passer l'hiver le groupe GDR a déposé
une centaine d'amendements qui vise à
mettre en place des garde-fous à
corriger la copie c'est avec cet état
d'esprit que nous entamons ce débat
passionnant
merci Monsieur jumelles la parole est à
Monsieur Bricout du groupe libertin
indépendant outre-mer et territoires
simplement sur la planification en
particulier et sur l'éolien terrestre
qui pose effectivement des problèmes sur
notre territoire je crois que on est
quelques-uns sans soucier aujourd'hui
madame la ministre le constat est clair
on est les derniers élèves du de
l'Europe pour un pays qui quelquefois et
un président qui donne des leçons à
l'Europe des leçons au monde entier je
dois avouer que ça fait un petit peu
désordre d'être mauvais élève en fin de
compte en matière de production des
énergies renouvelables et c'est bien
dommage et comme je disais je pense que
on aurait préféré avoir un an du texte
qui soit dans enfin que le texte dans le
bon ordre à partir de ce conseil
évidemment on ne peut que
c'est difficile quelque part de se poser
au texte sur les objectifs en tous les
cas de ce texte ici et là bien sûr on
entend quelques divergences par rapport
au sujet du nucléaire mais je crois
qu'il faut pas perdre de vue de choses
qui sont de toute façon sur c'est que le
nucléaire si on doit le développer ben
c'est pas avant 10 ans par contre
l'usage électrique l'électrification des
usages c'est tout de suite donc à partir
de là le texte je pense que ce soit au
niveau de notre groupe que ce soit au
niveau quelquefois des populations on
voit bien qu'il faut de toute façon
accélérer ses production de l'éolien le
problème jusque là je vais dire tout va
bien mais c'est quand on arrive dans la
déclinaisons sont nos territoires la
déclinaison des objectifs que là ça
commence à poser problème donc laisser
je pense qu'il faut laisser aux élus
laisser la population c'est
responsabilités on est capable de savoir
faire sur votre territoire de ce qu'on
veut c'est pouvoir refuser des projets
je vous l'ai dit quand c'est quand des
projets ne sont pas tout simplement
partagés quand ils sont pas quand ils ne
sont pas désirés tout simplement sur
notre territoire
alors on vous a proposé quelques
dispositions c'est venu d'ailleurs sur
plusieurs bancs de même de l'opposition
je crois qu'il y avait Delphine bateau
qui avait proposé enfin qui propose
toujours d'ailleurs de définir un indice
de saturation visuelle je pense que ça
peut faire partie des éléments qui
peuvent être entendus ou qui peuvent
être dans tous les cas expertiser moi je
vous ai proposé de définir un taux
d'effort en deux mots c'est de se dire à
partir du moment on a des études
objectifs régionaux de pouvoir les
décliner sur une communauté de communes
et une fois qu'on a rempli ces objectifs
on a même proposé 10% de plus éjelectifs
de pouvoir dire non en disant bah
maintenant si c'est bien on le fera si
ça pose problème sur notre territoire
qu'on est le moyen juridique opposable
de pouvoir qu'on puisse s'opposer en fin
de compte à ces projets voilà je vous
remercie j'espère que vous sera notre
écoute et que les débats seront très
constructifs et très prometteurs merci
la parole est à Monsieur Tanguy du
groupe rassemblement national
[Applaudissements]
la présidente madame lapiniste recherche
pendant la campagne présidentielle nous
avions annoncé avec Marine Le Pen que le
fameux discours de Belfort d'Emmanuel
Macron n'était pas un plan de relance du
nucléaire mais une gigantesque promotion
des énergies intermittentes encore une
fois nous avions dit la vérité en
français encore une fois vous leur aviez
menti nous y sommes voilà la loi qui
doit doubler les éoliennes sur terre
dont les Français ne veulent plus voilà
la loi qui doit défigurer nos côtes sauf
au Touquet évidemment avec 50 parcs
d'éoliennes sur mer dont les Français ne
veulent pas le cadre que vous voulez
apposer à la France prévoit toujours de
survaloriser les éoliennes alors
qu'elles ne fonctionnent pas vous
prévoyez toujours de survaler les
éoliennes en mer alors qu'elles n'ont
pas fonctionné dans les pays voisins
nous le voyons aujourd'hui à l'inverse à
l'inverse vous méprisez vous méprisez
systématiquement avec le même avec le
mort d'ailleurs les énergies
renouvelables qui pourraient fonctionner
ce sont les énergies renouvelables que
nous promouvons au rassemblement
national avec Marine Le Pen pourquoi ne
déployer vous pas tout ce que nous ils
vont faire comme potentiel
hydroélectrique vous refusez d'aborder
ce débat je remarque que la voix du
nucléaire a enfin parlé du déploiement
des steppes qui avait parlé du
déploiement des stations de pompage
massif pendant la présidentielle c'est
Marine Le Pen et personne d'autre je
vois que vous refusez toujours de parler
du développement massif de la géothermie
qui en avait parlé comme énergie
renouvelable c'est Marine Le Pen je vois
que vous avez enfin timidement commencer
à parler d'hydrogène même si les actes
ne suivent pas qui a parlé d'hydrogène
depuis 2005 c'est Marine Le Pen donc en
fait cette loi cette loi n'est pas le
procès des énergies renouvelables cette
loi est le procès des énergies stupides
et aveugle que vous continuez à imposer
aux français malgré vos échecs malgré
les factures cette loi une fois plus je
le dis est une loi idéologique c'est une
loi obsolète mais c'est surtout une loi
cynique c'est le cynisme propre à la
macronie vous retournez systématiquement
les aspirations des Français contre même
vous leur faisait miracle miroiter
quelques Ré nucléaire pour faire
diversion pour imposer des milliers de
ma éoliennes sur terre et en mer des
milliers de panneaux photovoltaïques
vous faites miroiter aux Français une
politique souveraine alors que vous ne
faites qu’appliquer la folie allemande
comme je l'ai déjà dit et vous refusez
systématiquement d'en parler d'ailleurs
un panier vous nager pouvez-vous enfin
nous dire où en est le contrat d'échange
entre le gaz français pas le gaz que les
Français ont acheté et l'électricité que
l'Allemagne est censé nous fournir nous
avons toujours aucune transparence sur
ce domaine là votre aveuglement est tel
qu'il faut encore donner à notre chiffre
le bouclier tarifaire qui est là
uniquement pour effacer vos erreurs et
pour nous et pour protéger les Français
de vos propres turpitudes va coûter plus
de 100 milliards d'euros c'est à dire
plus cher que le parc nucléaire français
que nous avons construit pendant 20 ans
bref cette loi oui mais la bannir une a
fait ce sont les clips de Monsieur le
Maire vous les peut-être que vous les
ignorez bref la loi que vous allez que
nous allons discuter ici n'a aucun sens
autre que de toujours reproduire les
mêmes erreurs ce ne sont pas les
énergies renouvelables que nous refusons
c'est votre aveuglement c'est votre
irrationalité et il faut bien le dire
votre irresponsabilité soutenir votre
loi c'est condamner toute vrai
transition énergétique pour lier notre
destin au gaz russe et au gaz
qatari c'est condamné les Français à la
précarité énergétique c'est condamner
les Français à la pauvreté organisée
cette loi n'est pas mauvaise elle est
suicidaire et donc nous la combattrons
merci Monsieur Tanguy
la parole est à Madame gaieté du groupe
la France insoumise
[Applaudissements]
présidente ministre collègue avec ce
projet de loi vous nous demandez
d'accepter la pagaille et
l'improvisation sous couvert une
nouvelle fois de l'urgence de la
situation mais cette fois-ci l'urgence
est énergétique votre impréparation
est-elle que vous nous annoncez
prochainement des écoles fermées fautes
d'électricité alors les jets privés vont
pouvoir continuer de voler les panneaux
publicitaires resteront allumés mais les
parents que l'on informera la veille il
ne leur restera que l'énergie du
désespoir face à l'urgence donc votre
projet de loi sur les renouvelables
n'est pour l'instant qu'un micmac
administratif peut compréhensible et
manquant cruellement de vision politique
au menu des dérogations à tire-larigot
et une planification sans plan un
exemple pour en résumer l'esprit vous
prévoyez de créer des zones
d'accélération pour les énergies
renouvelables c'est à vrai dire le
dispositif central de votre grande
ambition planificatrice or rien n'est
prévu pour vous assurer que ces zones
accueillent effectivement des
installations de production d'énergie
renouvelables pour atteindre nos
objectifs de production et rien ne dit
non plus qu'il n'y aura pas
d'installation de production d'énergie
renouvelable hors de ces zones donc
pourquoi un tel dispositif la réponse
c'est la toile de fond de votre texte
l'idéologie de votre gouvernement
l'obsession de la macronie c'est le
marché aux États-Unis Biden met 400
milliards sur la table pour l'industrie
et pour la souveraineté énergétique ici
Macron pense sortir des énergies
fossiles en ne faisant aucun
investissement public conséquent et en
créant 14 postes pour la transition
énergétique vous laissez donc le champ
libre aux entreprises privées et vous
jurez aux Français qu'ils auront bien du
courant en appuyant sur l'interrupteur
vous ne voulez pas dans le fond que
l'État reprennent la main et
garantissent enfin notre indépendance
énergétique
en résumé la loi doit être à la hauteur
de l'enjeu et ce n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui lorsque nous commençons son
examen notre groupe est clair des
renouvelables oui l'accélération aussi
mais pas n'importe comment et pas à
n'importe quelle condition nous
refuserons donc toutes les dispositions
cheval de Troie du soutien nucléaire qui
se cache dans votre texte et elles sont
nombreuses comme le soutien à
l'hydrogène bacarbone nous refuserons
tout agrivoltaïsme qui artificialise les
sols et nuit à notre souveraineté
alimentaire nous ferons au mieux pour
que ce texte intègre les dispositions
indispensables pour la concertation
citoyenne la protection des filières
industrielles le contrôle public de ce
secteur et des moyens suffisants pour
l'État nous amendrons également pour que
les zones déjà artificialisées les
parkings les toitures les délaissés
autoroutiers notamment permettent
prioritairement l'accélération dont nous
avons besoin en résumé madame la
ministre les Français ont froid ils
n'ont plus le temps pour vos petits pas
soyez à la hauteur et revoyez votre
copie merci
merci
la parole est à Monsieur Maquet du
groupe les républicains
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la ministre
Messieurs les Présidents mes chers
collègues les Français vivront cet hiver
une véritable angoisse celle de voir
leur pays grande puissance mondiale
autrefois leader de l'électricité
décarbonée relégué auront non seulement
des importateurs mais des plus exposés
au risque de rupture d'approvisionnement
madame la ministre vous devez l'assumer
car cela fait pardon car cela fait 10
ans que votre idéologie est au pouvoir
10 ans de démantèlement de notre filière
d'excellence de super Phénix au projet
d'Astrid en passant naturellement par la
fermeture de Fessenheim 10 ans de
subventions massive à une électricité
intermittente 10 ans de désarmement face
au défi climatique énergétiques où nous
étions pourtant les leaders mondiaux
grâce à une industrie nucléaire
florissante que le monde entier nous
envié vous nous dites que les énergies
nous renouvelables sont en train de
rembourser les investissements publics
Pharaon dont elles ont bénéficié
pourtant le compte n'y est pas le
montant total des engagements pris pour
le soutien aux énergies renouvelables et
estimées entre 120 et 150 milliards
d'euros alors que les recettes estimées
par la crue à l'occasion de cette hausse
des prix insupportable pour les Français
sont à peine 31 milliards d'euros pour
le groupe les républicains le vrai
intérêt public majeur c'est de
réindustrialiser la France mes chers
collègues accélérons la relocalisation
du textile de l'automobile de la
sidérurgie de l'industrie made in France
rien industriels à sa France s'est évité
le carbone induit par la production des
pays fortement en retard en termes
d'empreintes carbone vous le voyez
madame la ministre vous devez entendre
nos arguments et ne pas franchir ces
lignes rouges si vous souhaitez
recueillir notre soutien sur ce texte
dans le cadre contraire vous assumerez
la responsabilité de la colère des
Français qui se rendent compte de
l'impasse dans laquelle notre pays est
plongé par de telles politiques motivées
par une idéologie qui nous a déjà
conduit à l'échec je vous en remercie
la parole est à Monsieur mienne du
groupe démocrate mes chers collègues
nous nous retrouvons aujourd'hui pour
étudier l'un des textes les plus
importants de cette mandature et je suis
très fier d'être devant vous pour le
défendre c'est un texte ambitieux et qui
prouve la volonté de notre majorité de
travailler avec tous ceux qui veulent
honnêtement préparer notre pays pour
atteindre nos objectifs climatiques les
défis sont immenses et notre retard est
déjà très important nous n'avons pas le
choix est utile de rappeler pourquoi car
même si nous consommons moins d'énergie
ça a déjà été rappelé nous aurons besoin
d'environ 60% d'électricité en plus
d'ici 2050 par rapport à aujourd'hui
parce que aussi le nucléaire ne suffira
pas
faire sortir de terre des centrales
nucléaires prend du temps beaucoup de
temps et en même temps 12 réacteurs
arriveront en fin de vie en 2035 nous
n'aurons donc pas le temps nécessaire
pour satisfaire nos besoins en
électricité qu'avec du nucléaire parce
que le nucléaire coûte cher très cher
près de 52 milliards d'euros pour la
construction de 6 PA2 sur une durée de
25 ans
parce qu'un scénario 100% nucléaire se
heurterait à la faisabilité
technologique et industrielle selon la
filière elle-même il existe une forme de
plafond de capacité industrielle de 14
réacteurs nucléaires nouveau à horizon
l'heure est donc à l'action en mettant
un grand coup d'accélérateur au projet
d'énergie renouvelable en France les
quatre-vient premières éoliennes en mer
voient à peine le jour en France alors
que 5700 tournent déjà en Europe il est
rare de pouvoir se targuer d'avoir
travaillé sur un texte de cette
importance un texte qui marque une
inflexion non pas pour le quinquennat à
venir mais pour des décennies il y a de
cela près de 40 ans nos prédécesseurs
ont défini la politique énergétique de
notre pays et nous bénéficions encore
aujourd'hui de ces retombées positives
nous avons la même responsabilité
aujourd'hui c'est non seulement une
responsabilité pour nous-mêmes mais
aussi pour nos enfants pour notre pays
et pour l'Europe pensons aux biens
communs dépassons nos clivages habituels
et votons ce texte je vous remercie
merci Monsieur miel la parole est à
Madame baptistel du groupe socialiste
apparenté
madame la présidente madame la ministre
madame et Messieurs les rapporteurs
chers collègues le groupe socialiste qui
apparenté c'était exprimé de manière
particulièrement critique quant au
contenu du projet de loi d'accélération
des énergies renouvelables qui nous
avait été présentés en août dernier je
ne reviendrai pas sur la question du
calendrier inversé entre tous les textes
les projets de loi énergie prévus dans
l'année qui vient ENR nucléaire EDF PPE
nous en avons longuement parlé mais
avoué madame la ministre qu'il est
difficile de définir les outils de mise
en oeuvre d'une programmation à
l'aveugle d'autre part la sobriété la
grande oubliée alors même qu'elle doit
être au cœur de nos politiques
énergétiques au même titre que les ENR
le texte lui-même ne comportait
d'ailleurs aucune mesure de
planification territoriale conditions
même du succès de cette accélération
aucune mesure de développement de
l'énergie solaire sur des surfaces déjà
artificialisées ou presque rien sur la
chaleur renouvelable ou encore
l'hydroélectricité alors même que
l'augmentation de puissance des ouvrages
existants n'est pas encore effective
trois ans après la loi énergie climat
qui le permettait qu'attendons-nous dans
cette loi il y a un certain nombre de
simplification et de coordination
utile notamment pour les liens en mer
et d'autres où l'utilité des mesures
proposées était plus discutables comme
le Sénat lui-même soulevé
sur les délais de procédure par exemple
nous ne devons pas légiférer au seul fin
de placer une rustine pour cacher le
problème central et majeur qu'elle
insuffisance des moyens de l'État dans
les territoires d'une part pour
instruire les projets et d'autres parts
pour instruire les recours l'arrêt de
suppressions de postes dans le PLF 2023
met fin à l'hémorragie madame la
ministre il ne redonne pas audreal au
DDT à la justice administrative des
moyens suffisants et en tout cas au
niveau de l'ambition que nous avons pour
le développement des énergies
renouvelables le Sénat a largement
contribué à améliorer ce projet de loi
en lien avec le gouvernement et nombre
de critiques qui étaient les nôtres qui
ont trouvé un commencement de résolution
notamment sur la planification
territoriale
nous avons identifié lors des débats de
points durs qui demeure dans le texte et
qui font encore obstacles un vote
favorable de notre part car notre
ambition est bien d'améliorer toujours
plus ce projet de loi afin de pouvoir le
voter presque comme le nôtre cette
première ligne rouge est la question du
solaire au sol en particulier en zone
agricole nous pensons que le
photovoltaïque doit d'abord être
développé sur les zones artificialisées
et nous avons fait des propositions en
ce sens en commission nous avons ainsi
obtenu que le nouvel de couverture des
toitures des nouveaux bâtiments
tertiaires soit porté de 50 à 60% de
leur surface par exemple même si nous
considérez nous considérons que nous
pouvons faire davantage et nous
proposons de faire des zones d'activités
économiques des zones prioritaires de
développement des énergies renouvelables
la définition du solaire au sol en zone
agricole à l'article 11 des siestes tels
que proposer en commission aurait permis
à ces projets de se sans entrave nos
sous-amendements adoptés en commission
et permettant de durcir sa définition en
marquer un premier pas mais qui reste
insatisfaisant les nombreuses
sollicitations
d'énergéticiens reçues depuis nous ont
conforté dans notre haleine nous avons
poursuivi nos débats sur cette question
ces derniers jours et avons formulé une
proposition de rédaction qui permet de
trouver une issue favorable notre
deuxième ligne rouge c'est ensuite la
question du partage de la valeur nous
l'avons dit celle-ci doit profiter au
territoire sans remettre en cause le
principe cardinal de la péréquation
tarifaire et c'est ce que vous aviez
proposé pourtant l'accueil
d'installation de production de NR n'est
pas une charge qui implique une
indemnisation mais une contribution à un
effort national qui justifie des
retombées positives à cet égard nous
nous sommes totalement opposés à une
forme de retour notamment aux
particuliers par une remise sur la
facture d'électricité ce mécanisme sera
source de conflits de jalousies de
voisinage entre les habitants parfois
d'une même rue selon les modalités du
zonage infinies cela se fera au
détriment des projets de plus cela aura
un coup qui sera supporté par les
charges de service public donc par les
autres contribuables nous avons senti en
commission que la majorité était
également divisée sur ce point et cela
demeure pour nous un point extrêmement
dur nous portons une alternative celle
d'un fond qui permettrait de financer
des projets de rénovation énergétique
d'adaptation au changement climatique et
de lutte contre la précarité énergétique
financée par les porteurs de projets via
les collectivités du bloc communal
elle-même nous faisons ainsi le lien
entre production d'énergie sobriété et
justice sociale à la main de chaque
territoire une mesure qui favorisera
l'acceptabilité de ces projets en
transformant cet essai permettez nous de
voter votre texte qui devra ainsi notre
texte mais cela dépendra de l'issue des
débats de cette commission en tout cas
nous comptons sur votre écoute pour
pouvoir le faire je vous remercie
merci Madame Baptiste
la parole est à Monsieur Thiébaut du
groupe horizon et apparenté ce texte est
un texte d'avenir sur lequel le groupe
Horizon est apparenté est pleinement
engagé cette loi pour objectif d'assurer
à la France une énergie souveraine
compétitive et décarbonée cette loi pour
objectif d'assurer un ensemble de
concitoyens et concitoyennes de pouvoir
se chauffer cuisiner et se déplacer
enfin cette loi sera une véritable
opportunité économique pour notre pays
je rappelle que les énergies
renouvelables cette année l'année
prochaine vont ramener plusieurs
dizaines de milliards de recettes à
l'état les énergies renouvelables sur
une chance pour le territoire pour la
compatibilité de nos entreprises mais
aussi et surtout pour les générations
d'aujourd'hui et de demain j'espère que
les débats que nous aurons en séance
seront également productifs et que nous
sortirons des positions dogmatiques et
des logiques on essaie de poser sur des
débats des fois un petit peu esthétiques
je ne sais pas si il vaut mieux avoir
une éolienne au fond de son jardin ou
une centrale nucléaire je vous laisser
ai juge mais en tout cas il faut nous
faut une approche pragmatique car
l'avenir nous pouvons le prévoir mais
nous devons le permettre pour tous ces
raisons le groupe horizon votre en
faveur de ce projet de loi je vous
remercie
merci Monsieur Thiébaut
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à Monsieur Fournier du
groupe écologiste
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mesdames Messieurs les rapporteurs chers
collègues nous écologistes attendions
depuis longtemps un texte sur les
énergies renouvelables elle constitue
pour nous un des trois piliers d'une
politique énergétique efficace
écologique et socialement justes une
sobriété énergétique pour réduire nos
consommations et le gaspillage
l'efficacité énergétique à tous les
niveaux pour optimiser nos consommations
et une trajectoire 100% énergies
renouvelable pour produire une énergie
propre et remplacée la dépendance aux
énergies fossiles nous écologiste
attendions un texte pour rattraper le
retard de la France en matière de
déploiement des énergies renouvelables
en 2020 elles n'ont représenté que 19%
de la consommation finale contre les 23%
qui étaient prévus seul pays européens à
ne pas avoir atteint ses objectifs nous
avons plusieurs échanges vous avez
ouvert la porte nous espérons qu'elle ne
se refermera pas eu égard au chemin
parcourus par ce texte avec des plus et
des moins nous restons très attentifs au
débat nous ne sommes pas à l'abri de
mauvaises surprises ou de bonnes
surprises l'étang de nos débats mais
disons-le pour nous tout ne se joue pas
sur ce texte il serait inconcevable
d'essentialiser ce texte en disant que
nous serions dans l'an 0 des énergies
renouvelables nous n'avons pas avancé il
faut reconnaître ce qui n'a pas été fait
et pourquoi nous en sommes là mais il
nous faudra une loi de programmation
ambitieuse il nous faudra une
planification et les moyens qui vont
avec il nous faudra renforcer les
services de l'État c'est indispensable
pour réussir il nous faudra une ambition
pour l'appropriation collective de la
transition énergétique le débat qui est
alors j'ai été ce matin dans un des
débats de la CN organisée avec la CNDP
il y avait pas beaucoup de monde c'est
un débat un peu discret il me semble
qu'il nous faut un grand temps de
concertation beaucoup plus fort que
celui qui s'amorce aujourd'hui et sans
enfin sans une articulation efficace
avec les enjeux de s'embrouille été sans
un développement des filières j'en ai
parlé ne faisons pas jouer à ce texte ce
rôle si essentiel qu'il justifierait les
errements du passé et le renoncements
que nous avons déjà connus et qui
pourraient se reproduire nous souhaitons
qu'il soit un bon texte de méthode nous
y avons travaillé avec sérieux et nous
continuerons à le faire
madame la présidente Madame le Ministre
les rapporteurs
il n'y aura pas d'école le matin dans
les zones qui subiront des coupures de
courant programmés et cibler cet hiver à
confirmer ce jeudi 1er décembre le
ministre de l'éducation nationale Pape
Ndiaye des mots inimaginables
inenvisageables surréaliste en 2022 en
France pour clore tout débat le
gouvernement nous explique que c'est le
prix à payer de la guerre en Ukraine
excuse cynique alors que le peuple
ukrainien dans un froid glacial continue
de se battre pour arracher sa liberté la
vérité est moins héroïque puisque c'est
aussi le prix des Hermans de l'État
stratège et de l'absence de commande de
PR durant la décennie 2010 que nous
payons aujourd'hui
il y a 10 ans si la filière avait pu
lancer des chantiers nous aurions
davantage de salariés que nous aurions
pu déplacer vers les urgences à traiter
sur le parc actuel à marteler le PDG
d'EDF de l'époque Jean-Bernard les
villes lors de son audition à
l'Assemblée nationale en septembre
dernier résultat des courses 25 des 56
réacteurs du parc nucléaire français
sont aujourd'hui à l'arrêt une situation
qui dure depuis le printemps 2022
souvenons-nous par exemple de la
fermeture de Fessenheim l'argument
invoquait l'écologie ou plutôt une
certaine idée de l'écologie militante et
parfois même stupide car déconnecté du
réel en réalité une mesure pour raper le
ministre de l'Environnement d'alors un
certain Nicolas Hulot pour remédier à
cette situation il nous faut agir agir
pour sauver notre parc nucléaire en le
restaurant en le déployant et surtout en
innovant vite très vite
dans son discours de Belfort du 10
février 2022 Emmanuel Macron avait
décliné une stratégie pour l'avenir de
la production d'électricité française
reposant sur deux jambes avec la relance
du nucléaire et en même temps
l'accélération du déploiement des
énergies renouvelables son but
multipliait d'ici 2050 la production
d'énergie solaire par 10 déployée 50 par
éolien en mer et doubler la capacité
d'éoliennes terrestre seul bémol dans
cette stratégie il faut 50 procédures
pour valider un parc solaire 7 ans pour
un parc éolien et 10 ans pour un parc
Léon en mer et je ne parle même pas des
oppositions féroces et tenaces que
suscitent l'éolien rendant son
acceptation par les Français de plus en
plus difficile je suis très simplement
ici les deux parcs de Lespignan et de
Puissalicon chez moi dans les Rhône ou
du fait ou du fait d'une forte
mobilisation les projets éoliens ont
finalement été abandonnés
pour trouver un juste équilibre entre
développement des énergies renouvelables
et respect de nos territoires il faut
commencer par donner plus de pouvoir au
niveau local favoriser l'écoute la
concertation et parfois même la
codécision j'ai d'ailleurs déposé en ce
sens un certain nombre d'amendements
pour que les mères et leurs conseils
municipaux puissent jouer un véritable
rôle en validant ou non les projets
d'implantation de NR sur leur commune
tout comme il est crucial de consulter
la population locale et puis il faut
innover avec notamment l'hydrogène des
carbonées ou bas carbone il peut être
produit en ayant comme source non
seulement le photovoltaïque l'éolien
mais aussi le nucléaire selon l'édition
2022 des chiffres clés des énergies
renouvelables trois régions atteignent
un niveau de consommation d'électricité
renouvelable supérieure à 45% de la
consommation totale d'énergie le Grand
Est l'Auvergne Rhône-Alpes et
l'Occitanie parions ensemble qu'avec
l'hydrogène décarbonée nous pourrons
enfin parler à nouveau de souveraineté
énergétique et rapidement oublier que
cet hiver nos enfants pourraient bien ne
pas aller à l'école le matin je vous
remercie merci Madame Ménard
pour déployer à grande échelle les
énergies renouvelables le projet loi
préconise le recours aux surfaces déjà
artificialisée une manière de répondre
aux écologistes et aux insoumis qui
reprochent au gouvernement de ne pas
suffisamment prendre en compte la
sauvegarde de la biodiversité le projet
de loi entend également installé des
panneaux solaires sur les parkings dont
la surface excède 2500 mètres carrés
mais les députés ne l'entendent pas de
cette oreille ils vont parvenir à
relever l'ambition du texte
on a fait une série de d'amendements
donc je vais pas je vais les défendre
tous d'un coup il y a le 24 66 qui
arrive après bon là on est sur un
premier amendement qui vise juste à
montrer l'urgence je pense que c'est une
des urgences qu'on peut vraiment dont on
peut vraiment se saisir dans ce projet
de loi d'accélération sur les
renouvelables c'est de prioriser
absolument sur les zones déjà fortement
artificialisées et c'est évidemment le
cas des parkings de stationnement et
donc ça c'est un premier amendement qui
descend le seuil ici à 1000 mètres
carrés de 1500 m² ça nous paraît
vraiment insuffisant il semble en plus
qui est un seuil entre 1000 et 1500 m²
qui fasse gagner beaucoup beaucoup de
temps dans les procédures
d'autorisation et qui nous permettent
donc véritablement de d'accélérer et le
gisement photovoltaïque ça a été dit par
ma collègue Aurélie trouvée mais on doit
multiplier le photovoltaïque par 22 dans
les 30 ans à venir si jamais on le fait
pas sérieusement sur les parkings avec
des ombrières on ne le fera pas tout
court et on discutera après de la
grivevoltaïsme mais il est évident que
si là il y a pas un signal clair sur des
zones qui sont entièrement bétonnées sur
lequel on pourrait mettre véritablement
un coup de boost je crois qu'on arrivera
à rien si jamais on se met à rentrer
dans les détails ensuite sur des sur des
terres agricoles productives etc pour
nous la limite elle est claire entre ces
deux options et là je crois qu'il est
temps d'envoyer un message sur ce qu'on
était en train de faire dans cette
Assemblée nationale l'accélération PV
sur les parkings en ouvrière ça ne
détruit pas d'espèces ça ne pose pas de
problème sur la biodiversité et je pense
que c'est vraiment un facteur
d'accélération majeur madame gaieté
j'imagine que du coup vous avez défendu
le 2466
c'est 1500 mètres carrés oui
oui mais par contre on va retirer le
dernier de la série qui montait jusqu'à
2000 parce qu'il nous semble qu'on est
raisonnable et constructif mais enfin
que là c'était c'était un petit peu trop
et donc le dernier de la série à 2000
c'est le 2457 oui c'est ça exactement et
donc on en maintient deux avec deux
options l'une plus plus ambitieuse que
l'autre madame Pompili le 2788
là on va tous essayer de trouver le
seuil le plus adapté sachant que 2500 m²
c'est trop et donc là il y a des
propositions à 250 le mien c'est 500 il
y en a d'autres à 1000 essayons de voir
ce qui est le plus adapté mais
clairement on a besoin de baisser ce
seuil
merci le 232 monsieur Fournier
merci madame la Présidente alors j'ai
dit défendu mais on a proposé 250 on a
proposé 500 750 Emile voilà et c'est
notre dernier prix moi je mettrai un
avis favorable sur le sur le 2466 de
madame guettet qui est sur 1500 mètres
carrés
et qui nous permet pertinent pour
développer
les bons les bons ombres oui je sais
peut-être que c'est pas assez loin
monsieur Fournier mais pour autant voilà
avant sont déjà sur ce sur ce niveau là
de manière à ce qu'on puisse déjà
développer les ombrières sur cette
surface là et qu'on puisse répondre à
déjà à des
ambitions que nous avons au niveau
écologique
alors
ouais nous on effectivement on va
dans toute cette liste d'amendements se
sont propose de soutenir ces 2000 mètres
carrés 2000 mètres carrés c'est la
conversion des 80 places qui avaient été
votées au Sénat on sera ça permet de
réaligner les deux au passage pour
répondre à Madame gaieté qui soulevait
la question des procédures vous savez
que la procédure des 500 KVC était
augmenté et que maintenant ça correspond
à des parcs de 1 moins d'un mégawatt on
peut être dans la situation que vous
mentionnez c'est-à-dire en procédure
accélérée donc cette question de la
procédure allégée sur des plus petits
parcs elle ne se pose pas à 2000 mètres
carrés ou à 2500 mètres carrés je pense
que c'est important de le partager parce
que c'était un bon argument mais là il
tombe
ensuite nous en arrivons à un amendement
2466 alors là écoutez bien nous avons
mes chers collègues nous avions eu un
avis favorable de Madame Lam rapporteur
mais défavorable de Madame la Ministre
sagesse qui a donné un avis favorable
aux amendements qui viennent par la
suite
c'est clair pour tout le monde où je
répète
avis des avis favorables de Madame la
rapporteur et avis de sagesse de Madame
la Ministre qui a donné un avis
favorable à des amendements qui viennent
après donc qui est pour
qui est contre il est adopté et il fait
tomber tous les autres
[Applaudissements]
au total plus de 350 amendements dont
167 de l'opposition viennent enrichir ce
texte le 10 janvier séjour de vote alors
naturellement les trois groupes de la
majorité soutiennent ce projet de loi
mais c'est aussi le cas des socialistes
et des députés Lyot en revanche le
gouvernement ne convainc pas les
républicains ou le rassemblement
national mais aussi la France insoumise
et les communistes quant aux écologistes
ils s'orientent plutôt vers l'abstention
de quoi dessiner une issue favorable
pour le texte du Gouvernement
donc je vais vous annoncer le résultat
du scrutin sur le projet de loi relatif
à l'accélération de la production
d'énergie renouvelable et donc nous
avons un nombre de votants de 562
personnes ce qui montre bien que les
votes électroniques étaient défaillants
nombre de suffrages exprimés 524
majorité absolue 263 pour l'adoption
286 contre 238 donc l'Assemblée
nationale a adopté le projet de loi
[Applaudissements]
quelques semaines plus tard ce texte sur
l'accélération des énergies
renouvelables sera complétée par un
projet de loi pour favoriser la relance
du nucléaire c'est la fin de ce numéro
des grands débats merci à vous de
l'avoir suivi et à bientôt sur LCP
[Musique]